[Applause]
wow good to see you all how are
you we got a great crowd tonight welcome
to Hannity welcome back to our live
audience welcome to all of you at home
wow we have a ton of breaking news all
across the country in the world tonight
Trace Gallagher will join us from Israel
we have a breaking new update about the
hostages who are kidnapped by the
terrorist group Hamas and we are also
tracking a developing story out of Maine
where now at this hour a Manhunt is
underway for an act of shooter uh also
tonight according to a bombshell report
and this is a bombshell from foxnews.com
the FBI was contacted by over 40
confidential human sources over the
years all with criminal allegations
against Joe Biden Hunter Biden and James
Biden all dating back to Joe's term and
time as vice president so the question
is how did the FBI respond they did
nothing uh and by the way Charles
Grassley sent the FBI director and the
Attorney General a long letter today
demanding answers chairman Jim Jordan
who's also been investigating a lot of
this uh from the house Judiciary
Committee will join us with a lot more
by the way do you all hear we have a new
speaker
today I got to that
too also now I've interviewed Governor
Gavin Newsome twice he's going to be
debating Governor Ronda santis you know
Red versus Blue State versus State on
November 30th right here on this program
um he now has paid a visit to his
comrades in communist China including a
surprise meeting with President XI now
Nikki Haley as H she'll react to that
former un Ambassador also later a full
report on the pramas bigots now being
churned out at American universities
which is repulsive but first after weeks
of infighting the people house is now
back in business as of today Republicans
unanimously elected a brand new speaker
he is the 56 Speaker of the House
Louisiana Congressman Mike Johnson well
let's listen to him and his own words
from earlier today country it's the
beauty of America that allows a a
firefighters kid like me to come here
and serve in this sacred chamber where
great men and women have served before
all of us and strive together to build
and then preserve what Lincoln did refer
to as the last best hope of man on Earth
we stand at a very dangerous time I'm
stating the obvious we all know that the
world is in turmoil but a strong America
is good for the entire
world I believe that each one of us has
a huge responsibility today to use the
gifts that God has given us to serve the
Extraordinary People of this great
country and they deserve it and to
ensure that our Republic remains
standing as the great Beacon of light
and hope and freedom and a world that
desperately needs
it when our people are losing their
faith in government when when when
they're losing sight of the principles
that made us the greatest nation in the
history of the world I think we got to
be mindful of that we're going to fight
we're going to fight uh vigorously over
our core principles because they're at
odds a lot of times now in this modern
era we have to sacrifice sometimes our
preferences because that's what's
necessary in a legislative body but we
will defend our core principles to the
end we want our allies around the world
to know that this body of lawmakers is
reporting again to our duty stations let
the enemies of Freedom around the world
hear us loud and clear the people's
house is back in
business all right we're back to work
now we do have a big announcement we're
going to be broadcasting live from
Capitol Hill tomorrow where the house
Speaker Mike Johnson will join us for
his first television interview right
here on this show now Johnson is a
constitutional attorney he is relatively
new to the swamp in Washington I view
that as a plus but has developed a
strong conservative track record 92%
rating from the American conservative
Union 92% rating from the NRA backed by
former president Donald Trump uh Johnson
is a huge proponent of decentralizing
our federal government protecting your
children from woke PR predators securing
our Southern border strengthening
America's immigration laws vowing to
make this a top priority but his very
first act as Speaker was a resolution
backing Israel and condemning the
terrorist group
Hamas now nine Democrats voted against
the measure including all the members of
what I call the Hamas caucus led by
terrorist sympathizer uh congresswoman
to now socialist Jamal Bowman remember
him he voted against the measure now
today Bowman was charged with a
misdemeanor for pulling that fire alarm
at the capol complex oh I didn't know it
was a fire alarm said fire alarm as he
pulled it anyway that happened a few
weeks ago in what was an apparent
attempt to delay an important vote now I
tell you this if he were a Republican or
a trump supporter or his last name were
Trump he'd likely be facing 20 years to
life right now for multiple felonies uh
but in Biden's weaponized doj
heavy-handed managment is reserved only
for Joe's political opponents now
tonight without a doubt there are a lot
of very serious challenges that speaker
Mike Johnson will need to address this
caucus needs to learn a lesson they will
win together or they will lose together
there's not going to be some winners and
some losers in the Republican party and
the American people win if they win
because conservative values are far
superior to the left in their radical
new green deal climate alarmist cult
agenda of of radical socialism but
perhaps none more pressing than the
chaos and the violence that is unfolding
in the Middle East in large part I would
argue part of our problem in the Middle
East is because of your President Joe
Biden our country is now sleepwalking
into potentially another major war this
can engulf the entire region and for the
past two weeks American military
personnel they have come under attack
all over the region dozens are now
injured 10 Americans still being held
hostage by MOS over 30 Americans were
killed many others murdered Less Than 3
weeks ago that date October the 7th and
yet Joe Biden your commanderin-chief
doesn't really seem to have a plan or a
strategy or even the ability to a answer
simple questions it was being build all
day with Joe Biden press conference it
lasted all of nine minutes and he took a
whopping three questions take a look I
want to thank the Israeli the Israelis
and the Palestinians excuse me and
president CCE of Egypt we have had
troops in the region since
911 to go after Isis and prevent its re
reemergence in in both anyway in the
region AR these hostages uh in Jeopardy
if there is a ground invasion you want
to make a speech no look obviously
they're in Jeopardy rather than anything
else
oh I get that I get that okay uh PBS we
have a a request for a calling thank you
thank
you thank you everybody the press
conference has now concluded thank you
everyone go home and get the hell out of
here anyway that was built as a major
press conference by the White House Joe
took three questions it lasted nine
whole minutes while most news outlets
were FOC focused on the uh election of
the new house speaker and today well our
brand new speaker Mike Johnson said that
the world is a better place with a
strong America I couldn't agree more I I
couldn't be in more agreement Johnson is
right but unfortunately under Joe Biden
there is no strength there is no
leadership there is no moral Clarity we
had world leaders when he was in the
Middle East they said no to a meeting
with the president of the United States
of America even countries that we give a
billion or more dollars to a year
instead what we have is now very
transparent to anybody with eyes to see
a mumbling bumbling incoherent frankly
cognitive mess as our president trying
his best to read talking points from his
woke White House staffers that's not
cutting it make no mistake there is a
lot of evil in this world there are
terrorists that Revel in the murder of
even little innocent babies and the
elderly there are many others who excuse
or celebrate what are by barbaric acts
of Terror and there is the Islamic
Republic of Iran behind all of it
America needs the strongest toughest
leader willing and able to put punish
our enemies restore peace through
strength and that means America
regaining and retaking its role
as on the world stage as the world's
leader Joe Biden is not that guy he
doesn't have the mental aptitude he
doesn't have the moral Clarity he
doesn't have the moral courage he is a
creature of the Washington swamp he
doesn't even know today is Wednesday
Decay we see him decaying right before
our very eyes our country deserves
better and I fear that many troubling
days are ahead the 2024 presidential
election it can't come soon enough hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else